so with the age of apocalypse starting
on Monday we first need to jump in and
make a video about Bishop and the reason
for this is because while Bishop was
most prominent during his run with the
x-men in the 1990s he's quite possibly
the single most important character in
the Age of Apocalypse and that he's the
reason for the recognition that things
aren't the way they're supposed to be
and the basis basically the plan is
formed by Magneto which results in the
defeat of apocalypse at the end of the
Age of Apocalypse of in now while Bishop
first appears in uncanny x-men issue
number 282 in 1991 his origin story is
actually given to us in his solo series
which is titled Xavier security
enforcers in 1996 but over the course of
his existence and Marvel Comics we've
also received these little tidbits of
information regarding what brought about
his future and so what we'll be doing
here is basically folding all these
elements all these things together to
give you this full origin story of
Bishop in Marvel Comics proper now what
we're told in this original story from
the Xavier security enforcers series is
that Bishop grew up in a future very
similar to the Days of Future past in
the sense that at some point an event
happened in the history of this reality
which resulted in the relaunch of The
Sentinel program and their eventual
takeover of North America now we're in
the Days of Future Passed humans a
mutant existed in subservience -
sentinels and with no real end in sight
in bishops timeline and have been
occurred called the Sommers rebellion
where humans of mutants banded together
to eliminate the signals entirely which
resulted in this sort of uneasy truce
between humans and mutants themselves
now there's part of this truce mutants
are basically allowed to police
themselves resulting in the
establishment of the Xavier security
enforcers agency which was really named
after the x-men and Charles Xavier
himself but Bishop himself along with
his sister shard were actually born
during the summers rebellion but before
the liberation of both humans and
mutants and so due to being born in a
concentration camp
they were both branded with an M on
their faces to establish that they were
mutants to anyone who looked at them now
once the Sommers rebellion ends and with
vision shard into their preteen years
probably around maybe 12 or 13 years old
both individuals had idolized a group
called the X tombs which were very
extreme radicals very similar to the
present-day Brotherhood of Evil Mutants
and the reason for Bishop and shard
idolizing this group was because as they
had grown up they were constantly told
stories of the action by their
grandmother but without actually having
met the x-men themselves Bishop and char
basically grew to believe that the
actions of the exo-m's fell in line with
what the x-men would have done under
this situation but ultimately their
views change when shard is attacked and
kidnapped by the X tombs and she's
rescued by the X se now once both shard
and Bishop grow into their late teens
around the age of 16 or 17 of course I'm
just kind of guessing they don't really
give us an actual age here they both end
up joining the XS sea in an effort to
honor the memory of their late
grandmother and the memory of the x-men
but during this time char becomes
attached to one of the students named
Trevor Fitzroy now where Fitzroy was
eventually revealed to be a criminal
shard found herself extremely attached
to Fitzroy and when Fitzroy was
recruited by a subset of the Xavier
security enforcer is called the Xavier
underground enforcers in order to travel
to the present-day and stop the event
that it caused their timeline shard had
basically turned against Trevor leading
to Bishop travelling to the present day
in order to stop Fitzroy now in terms of
bishops continuity and Marvel Comics
this moment of Bishop traveling into the
present day from his future is basically
his first chronological appearance with
uncanny x-men number 282 now when Bishop
first arrives in the past arisin arrives
in the present-day weather to capture
Fitzroy he's immediately enamoured by
the arrival of the x-men but he believes
that the presence of the x-men is
actually some kind of trick or some kind
of ruse at the hands of Fitzroy and so
he begins battling the x-men now during
this battle Bishop demonstrates his
power to absorb massive amounts of
energy and actually project that energy
back meaning that he can basically
absorb the optic blasts of Cyclops and
project them back as the same form of
energy or as a concussive blasts of
energy he can absorb the explosive
nature of gambits throwing cards you can
make you can absorb the weather of a
storm whenever she uses her powers on
him again you can do this with a massive
amount of energy but one is up happening
here is that again while Trevor Fitzroy
escapes that over the course of issues
number 282 going to issues number two
and
95 the bishop uses this time to continue
his mission to capture Trevor Fitzroy
but he also monitors the x-men now in
issue number 285 Bishop's actually
successful in capturing Trevor Fitzroy
and setting it back to the future but
he's also come to the conclusion that
these x-men are legitimate they are the
real deal and so what he does is he
basically takes this time to stay in the
past or stay in the present day in order
to try to find or keep an eye out for
the event that causes his future and
keep it from happening and that's his
entire purpose and Marvel Comics all the
way from the time that he first shows up
in the original uncanny x-men number 282
until the events of the Messiah Complex
and his purpose is to basically keep an
eye out for what the event is that
causes his timeline to take place and
stop the event so that his timeline will
never come to fruition it'll never be as
dark as it is now again from the time
that he first showed up until the
Messiah Complex we never found out what
the event was Marvel never told us they
dropped hints from time to time which
indicated that there was possibly a
traitor associated with the x-men or
possibly even one of the x-men
themselves was the traitor but it was
never stated absolutely by Marvel in
2007 this all changed with the fallout
of the House of M and the Messiah
Complex storyline what we're told is
that when the squad of which had
stripped 98% of the mutant population of
their powers that within a year a child
was born as the first mutant born since
the house of M event and over the course
of the Messiah Complex event itself it's
revealed to us at this child which is
now referred to as Hope Summers would
actually go on to kill 1 million humans
which was the reason for why bishops
timeline came into existence in the
first place now of course as we know now
bishops timeline is not going to happen
simply because we know the multiverse is
gone all those different things were
simply existing with secret Wars but
with regards to the Age of Apocalypse
event itself what we're going to find
here is that with Bishop having
originated in the future of an alternate
reality when the Age of Apocalypse kicks
off he's not going to be affected by the
change in reality and so as a result
he'll be the catalyst for why magneto
enacts a plan to overthrow apocalypse
and restore the timeline back to normal
well that being said we're going to go
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know
and I will catch you guys later peace